this is how it looks from space the
blood-red stain of 21,000 tons of diesel
that will take weeks to clear and
decades to heal the worst ever
industrial spill in the polar Arctic now
heads are rolling
the mayor of the industrial city of
Norilsk charged today with criminal
negligence and three top managers at the
plant detained after investigators said
the leaky fuel tank was flagged as
unsafe in 2018 already lit slum
committee at the mercy producer Samir /
yet despite its critical condition and
in violation of safety rules this
spokesperson says the storage tank was
used by Smirnov Stepanov and deputy
chief engineer yuri kuznetsov this has
resulted in the emergency nickel and
palladium giant Norilsk Nickel which
owns the plant says it believes melting
permafrost is to blame 65% of russia
sits on permafrost environmentalists say
this is a wake-up call
generally this is the challenge for
their whole infrastructure not only no
risk in particular this situation again
that's about 100,000 2004 gas pipelines
for nuclear reactors Hydra dam dams 4
million people living there so this is
big big risk for all infrastructure some
diesel has spread beyond the containment
barriers into a nearby lake from there
it could drift north into Russia's
Arctic Nature Reserve nor Nikko CEO
Vladimir Potanin
one of Russia's richest men has told
President Putin that whatever the cost
he will pay security council chief
Nikolai patrushev one of Russia's most
powerful men who said that this accident
plays into the hands of those wishing to
discredit Russia's Arctic policy Diana
Magnay Sky News Russia